hold up wait wait wait did you just say
every woman here is a pick me
more or less not you oh no no no
wait wait wait wait wait how is
how is understanding
how the other species
operates and how what they value what
they want how is understanding them a
pick me when we always say wait wait
wait when we always say that they need
to understand women they need to
understand woman it's like how are you
supposed to be in a relationship with
someone you when you get in a
relationship with friends you try to
understand your friends who and you want
them to understand you so you can grow
that relationship you could be the best
friend they have in that relationship
how are you going to be one-sided and
say oh we don't need to understand man
we don't need to know this about men
they need to understand us and how we
operate and that's a pick me if we try
to understand how they operate to be
able to have a good relationship to not
be single at 40 with 12 kids to not die
alone with a dog how is that a pick me
well [ __ ]